[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you on Thursday 23rd
of March I'm Cindy The Spectators
assistant editor coming up on the show
Boris Johnson is in the news again but
it's his time in the Limelight while in
Chuli over I'll be speaking to Katie
pools
the pandemic might be over but it turns
out there are over a hundred thousand
children who never return to school
after they were closed during lockdown
what's going on Harriet Sergeant looks
at Britain's ghost children for the
cover piece this week she joins me on
the show along with Miriam Kate's MP
from education to policing the Met
police have received another damning
report this week it's the force Beyond
repair Danny Shaw has been looking at
the story and he joins me on the show
and over to the east she has just
returned to China after three days in
Moscow is Chinese neutrality on a
Ukraine War Slipping and what else is he
looking at to get out of his friendship
with Putin Gideon ragman joins me to
discuss
and finally a crash course on exoplanets
now if you have no idea what they are
stay tuned as astronomer Sasha Hinckley
tells me all about them and why them
just may be live in outer space
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode and if you want to read more
from The Spectator then why not
subscribe to the magazine too for just
12 pounds you can get 12 weeks in print
and online and a free 20 pound Amazon
voucher just go to spectator.co.uk
forward slash TV offer to subscribe
first up we looked yesterday at the
trial of Boris on spectator TV following
his party gate probe whilst the entire
day along with the tiny brexit repellent
simply an edifying for the former prime
minister with me to discuss is our
political editor Katie Bulls
now Katie I won't make you recall
everything that went on on Wednesday in
Parliament because you and Fraser
already did that in that spectator TV
special yesterday but tell me is
everything that has happened over the
course of this week showing that the
Boris Jones and supporters that faction
in Parliament is now a bit of a spent
Force yeah I think it is fair to say it
hasn't been a good week for Boris
Johnson you never quite know these you
know
the famous Boris Johnson uh quote which
is you know there's no such thing as
disaster you know only you know fresh
opportunities fresh disasters they can
often turn from one to the other
um so you don't know what's coming
around the corner but I think in terms
of this week alone the Privileges
committee I would say actually was
perhaps the school draw in terms of uh
Boris Johnson
um in the sense that there wasn't really
a Smoking Gun which moved the picture on
I think if you already thought Boris
Johnson was guilty of deliberately
misleading Parliament and your opinion
probably won't have changed and if you
already thought Boris Johnson was
innocent it was being ganged up on you
could probably also hold that opinion
from how it all played out and because
so much of the evidence was put in
advance there are tricky questions to
Boris Johnson when it comes to his
statements to Parliament he himself has
said this week that he did mislead the
house he is just saying that he didn't
do so intentionally
um and I think what's probably the
trickiest thing is the fact that some of
his colleagues at the time
um are saying oh well I did say he's you
know I didn't I didn't give this
complete Assurance would you sometimes
get the impression from Boris Johnson
he's claiming he did get
um but in terms of moving things on and
I don't think it it moved the dial so
much in terms of this big session and
what about the brexit votes then because
that also happened during the Committee
hearing and we heard uh in the morning
of Wednesday that Boris Johnson was
going to vote against so I think this is
actually the more significant in terms
of uh Boris Johnson's position within
the Tory party of course the Privileges
committee could lead to a by-election
depending on the suspension so that will
have a very material effect of so but
when it comes to the vote on The Windsor
framework I think it's interesting first
that you had a situation where is Sunex
she chose to hold that vote on Wednesday
when he knew Boris Johnson was going to
be in Parliament
um Borussia is not in Parliament every
day and and therefore it was almost I I
think you know some will say oh it's
just a coincidence I think these things
in politics are rarely pure coincidence
and it was almost saying to Boris
Johnson put your money where your mouth
is you you said you don't like this deal
and you've got those who's either back
it or don't back it and he chose to vote
against us it was quite a small number
of Tory MPS racing against it that's 22.
now there's lots of different spin going
around about what this result means
um the ERG well these one figure was
suggesting that actually if you look at
the abstentions to those who did not
vote either way despite being a Freeland
whip that's 48 Tory MPS if you add it up
if you imagine that every opposition MP
voted against it the government would
not have a working majority however it's
always a bit more complicated than that
and the abstentions included Grant chaps
who's a cabinet minister and the people
are allowed to miss the vote free
pairing so there will be some who chose
to abstain because they don't like the
policy and there'll be some who just
missed the vote for other reasons and
and also to choose to abstain around to
vote against is a choice that is choose
to to be less of a problem for the
government and that means there are 20
tutorial MPS who either dislike Rishi
sunak or dislike the deal that much
that's not such a bad figure if you
think in February there are warnings
that up to a hundred Tory MPS could vote
against vote against
um the any new deal in the protocol and
it meant that Richard Cena I don't think
did have to rely on labor votes well
especially because the dup and the ERG
both explicitly came out against about
do you think number 10 was surprised by
this how small the rebellion was I don't
think they were surprised and I think
that they still would have liked it to
be smaller
um I think
on a serious point it is a blow to ratio
Scenic that the dep have all voted
against the Windsor framework
um and I think there was a hope that for
example the dep leader would Jeffrey
Johnson would abstain
um and I think that probably matters
more than the the Tory MP rebellion and
because what does that mean for bringing
out power sharing and store months so
had the dup
um you know decided to abstain from this
you've perhaps had fewer Tory Rebels but
this is very far from the disaster
um which I think it could have been
proficiency had things uh you know
tensions around higher yeah and I saw
that Steve Baker had been kicked out of
her ERG WhatsApp group was that right I
mean he's had quite a quite a dumbest
thing conversion to the Russian Cena
cause yeah it's just in a way it feels a
little bit this way because though
perhaps reaching a bit of an end of an
era on some of the on some of the brexit
fighting now this could be very famous
last words and we'll be back in a few
weeks and I'll be telling you all the
vicious problems and how the ERG are
going to bring him down but Steve Baker
obviously now a minister
um in government former head of the ERG
has been lacking this deal lots of
people thought he might resign over it
and said he's been one of the most
passionate Defenders of it saying look
it might not be completely perfect but
it's the best thing for the people of
Northern Ireland and ultimately accused
Boris Johnson an interview on the day of
the vote of you know saying he shouldn't
vote against it he shouldn't be a pound
shop Nigel farage
um now this led to the ERG kicking him
out of a WhatsApp group and I think in
the past uh Steve Baker's kicked figures
out of WhatsApp groups
um but uh ultimately where does this
lead the European research group I think
it's partly parliamentary arithmetic but
they just do not at least for now hold
the same power as they did a few years
ago in terms of bell levels of Tory
party opinion
um and Katie I want to find out from you
what happened and with Boris Johnson
from here but but first just staying on
this idea of what you see like doing
relatively well is there a feeling
Investments that actually he is not
doomed in the next election that he's
actually doing performing higher Better
Than People expected no I think it
depends who you speak to I think in
Westminster
um and also as journalists we could
often jump from one extreme to another
so if you think that perhaps a year and
a half ago and lots of people predicting
um after local elections you know 10
more years of Boris Johnson
um saying you know he is impossible to
move then you get to a situation where I
it's I think it's pretty baked in
consensus labor heading to a large
majority and I think what we are seeing
is the tourism and not you know
completely done yet and we have a
situation where actually you saw it um
after Liz trust stepped down there was a
point when lots of Tory MPS did look a
bit into their abyss and think you know
what happens if we keep fighting and
they didn't like it and now and then you
see them moving back towards it but I
think a period of calm where she has
managed to make the political weather
that means that people are reassessing
him and thinking that at the very least
the next election will be more
competitive than it seemed a while ago I
mean we had one poll this week suggested
the labor leaders down to 10 points now
other polls suggest that it is nowhere
near that and it's still a steady
20-something lead if you get to a
consistent 10 point lead that's
obviously still significant for labor
but some labor politicians will start to
worry that if they've gone from a
30-something lead to 10 point how much
uh you know tighter is going to get
ahead of the next election and does
Harmony to be doing things differently
and
so we still have quite a weight
um
speaking to to one figure who thought
perhaps after the Privileges committee
it'd be half an hour and then they'd
announce their verdict um no such thing
and it will take weeks and months likely
we might even get um their reporter
after the local elections there's no
specific date yet and they will
recommend well they will say whether or
not they found Boris Johnson guilty as
charged and and then if they have found
him to have intentionally recklessly
misled Parliament and they will
recommend a punishment now the key thing
here is if it is a suspension is it 10
sitting days or more and if it is 10
sitting days or more then that would
mean that Boris Johnson was vulnerable
to recall petition that can then pave
the way to a by-election and with the
punishment the punishment does have to
be voted on in the House of Commons
Rishi Cena has said that will be a free
vote they're not going to try and tell
MPS they have to back Boris Johnson or
not back him and that's convention with
these types of votes
um but I think it's very likely the
punishment would pass and you know if
there's not any whipping going on and
and then in a by-election well let's see
I was trying to I was talking earlier
with some MPS about what could make
things you know good or bad for Boris
Johnson and there are looking at the
polls a by-election does not look very
good for Boris Johnson but there are
quite a few Tory MPS and these aren't
all the Hardline Borough restaurants and
supporters who actually think he could
um you know potentially be in a chance
of Defending it and and I wonder
actually if Boris Johnson somehow won a
by-election brought by the Privileges
committee is that the moment people
start to have more enthusiasm you'd hear
all his supporters suddenly saying see
we told you he's an election winner he's
a Chosen One Katie thank you so much
next new figures have emerged at 140 000
children never returned to school after
lockdown journalist and author Harriet
Sargeant has spent the last year
documenting some of Britain's ghost
children and the think tank the center
for social justice has also released a
new report on this issue Harriet's
written about it for the recovery piece
in a magazine this week and she joins me
now along with conservative MP Miriam
Cates who sits on the education Select
Committee
Harriet and Miriam welcome to spectator
TV thank you so much for your time today
um now Harry you've written in a
magazine about the plight of Britain's
ghost children 140
000 of them in the country what's
happened to these children well this is
quite extraordinary because in 2019
there were 60 000 children
um who were out of school more than they
spent time in school now we're you know
how many years are we from finishing
lockdown and yet the numbers are going
up I mean last year when I first looked
at it it was a hundred thousand so this
is a quite extraordinary increase and
from all the the this excellent report
from the center for social justice are
saying that the figures are going to
keep going up because this is a problem
that has not been recognized by
government and which government are
doing nothing about that's incredible
and it falls on a center for social
justice and a journalist like yourself
to bring it to like this this I mean
it's it is quite shocking actually why
do you think the numbers are going up
since the end of lockdown I think that
nobody has realized quite the long-term
damage that has been done to these kids
I mean I interviewed an awful lot of
them and they seem to fall in two parts
there seem to be those that and
generally these are girls but not
necessarily but to just can't go out of
their room they're just crippled by
anxiety they are really distressed
um they they essentially won't go out of
their room
um if they do go to school they manage
like one morning and then they go home
and then there are other The Other
Extreme mainly boys but not not always
Who Won't Go Back Home who are out on
the streets who are into all kinds of
things that they really shouldn't be
into and are angry and are bitter and
feel that they've simply I mean I
interviewed one in stretch from high
streets you said you know he's he was
hoping to get his his results to go to
college and he never got them and his
his dreams are broken and there's young
people like this Young Apprentice all
over the country whose dreams have been
broken and can't get those years back
and Miriam as an MP and the mother of
three you were one of the few
politicians to speak out against school
closures during the lockdown I mean is
this the kind of scenario that you
thought might have happened
well of course these are difficult
decisions and I wouldn't have wanted to
be in any of uh their shoes and uh you
know the Prime Minister former prime
minister has obviously been grilled this
week but I think we have a blind spot in
this country over Children's Welfare and
that wasn't just around the pandemic and
lockdowns we can see that in all many
many areas of our life and politics but
I think
children always should be the first
priority they are our future and we talk
a lot about vulnerable groups and
rightly so but the only truly vulnerable
group in society that we ought to be
protecting at all times is children and
we completely lost sight of them and of
course it's good to protect elderly
people of course it's good to protect
people with health challenges but
actually our top priority our number one
priority should have been children given
what we did know about the disease at
that point which was that it was very
very
um harmless to children and so I think
it's a just indicative of a wider blind
spot that we have in our politics which
is not putting Children First and I
think it was worse than that we actually
used children as a buffer against the
disease
um and to make older people feel safer
which again you know you can understand
politically but I think was the wrong
choice yeah well just on that Harriet
um when it comes to this disparity this
adult's not understanding children well
I was struck by in your piece was how
often kids knew what was going on kids
knew that their friends hadn't come back
to school but they had to go tell the
teachers who then had to take on their
parents so it seemed like the adults
just didn't have a grip on what was
going on whether that's teachers parents
or politicians indeed but the kids knew
what was going on well I mean this very
sad story that you mentioned about one
girl told me that a boy had dropped out
of school and she suddenly saw him
sitting by the side of the road looking
homeless just on on a bit of cardboard
you know very dirty very shabby and she
said he'd always been popular at school
so all the other kids were buying him
food bringing him clothes and finally
someone told the teacher so they got the
boy back into school but he was so far
behind and this is something that seems
to affected a lot of kids where they get
back into school they're so far behind
and he got very angry and he left and
and hasn't really been seen again how
much of it do you think is a poverty
issue as a class issue so like parents
who are you know time poor resource poor
just don't have the time to get their
kids back into school I mean that was
very interesting because there was
definitely the kids the most vulnerable
kids kids in disadvantaged areas on
preschool meals they all have double the
rates of of sort of dropping out to to
their contemporaries
um and certainly there are children who
I mean I know because I befriended um
four boys from a South London gang about
15 years ago and they are at the age of
15 had dropped out I mean they've always
been kids that have dropped out and they
would you know drug dealing and mugging
rather than going to school but look
what's happened to them I mean they in
the last 15 years have been in and out
of prison that's on a path yes
and at Great cost to themselves and and
to ask taxpayers and how are we going to
cope with that you know not 60 000
children but 140 000 and Rising how are
we going to cope with these numbers of
children
if they start going through the criminal
justice system I mean there doesn't seem
to be one uh government institution who
speaks for them I mean there's the
children's commissioner but who and
they're very eloquent but they they
don't have the power yeah people's going
to take responsibility for them well
Miriam let me ask you this question as
the politician in this conversation I
mean where were the adults during the
pandemic you know offstair the
Department of Education the children's
commissioner who I know has been looking
at this but clearly not enough has been
done
well I think the children's commissioner
is excellent and she does a great job of
of shedding light on some of these
issues but I think as Harriet said in
her article she doesn't have any power
um and I think the recommendations that
the csj have made in their report are
excellent about much more bespoke
um relationships to try and get children
back into school rather than a once it's
one size fits-all finding approach or
something like that so I think there's
some good recommendations but it's a
good question whose responsibility is it
I think again one of the problems that
potentially existed before lockdown but
was made very visible during lockdown is
that as a society we've kind of
privatized family life and we think that
all you need is a nuclear family and all
you need is the household and that if
you just have to retreat into your
household for two years well that's fine
but of course of course it's not fine
you know we exist we are social beings
we need each other not just for
resources and economic purposes but also
for company for learning you know all
these things that we interdepend on each
other for and you cannot just reduce
that to household units it doesn't work
um and again you know who is going to
take responsibility for that I don't
know of course part of it is the
government's responsibility but it's a
whole society responsibility and let's
forget not forget it wasn't only the
government that was shutting schools
down teaching unions were calling for it
some parents were calling for it the
media was certainly calling for it it
actually would have been very difficult
for the government not to do it from a
political point of view so we all share
that responsibilities as Society we were
all obsessed uh with the uh death
figures and the hospital figures
um and wearing masks and how the virus
traveled you know this was a national
Obsession and you know it may be
understandably but very few people in
any Walk of Life were speaking up for
the impact on children
um and I think you know we we are we're
reaping that now not just in educational
loss but in whole culture shifts about
whether education was optional or not
the value that people place uh on
education it's going to take a long time
to roll back is it Miriam what do you
think it needs to be done now I mean uh
Harriet writes very well in her piece
about how visitations for early years is
still not back you know some of these
things are still not back to normal as
we've heard about these ghost children
are actually increasing a number not
decreasing so what has to be done now
that we're out of the pandemic and what
does the government doing about it
well again in the report one of the
recommend recommendations is for um an
increased number of attendance officers
that sounds a bit formal but people to
go around building relationships with
families that are struggling and
coaching them back into school into
early years into society and I do think
that's the right approach I don't think
finding everybody or you know change
yeah changing
um a guidance across the board or
anything like that is going to help we
need a bespoke approach so I do I think
that is a good idea but I also think we
we need a mere culpr really we need some
adults somewhere to stand up and say
kids we got this wrong this was not in
your best interests education shouldn't
be optional you you you can't Thrive at
home on your own you need to be back at
school now that might seem a bit
tokenistic but I think when adults get
things wrong we know this as parents
it's important to own that otherwise how
does the how do the children know uh
that a mistake was made and actually
you're taking a new approach so I do
think we need that the government kind
of got in into that space a year ago
Nadine zahari said it was a mistake to
close schools which I think was a very
brave thing to do but we need something
much bigger than that to encourage
children to come back
um but you know these issues are very
complex there's not just one group of
children that's struggling yes
deprivation yes special educational
needs girls with anxiety boys who think
that the education system has failed
them anyway and now have seen all the
extracurricular activities canceled to
try and give them more maths lessons
there's a lot of questions we can ask
about the education system but I do
think as adults we need to signal that
we got it wrong Harriet yes I mean not a
lot of the children I interviewed were
very angry with their schools and that's
part of the problem because their
schools did nothing and the other thing
that I found so extraordinary was the
variability you know some schools went
out of their way to to to reach their
children see their children even feed
their children I mean as well as teach
them and others did absolutely nothing I
mean I had one boy who was meant to be
at an outstanding School in a sort of
very competitive and he gave up and
started to despair because he nobody was
marking his work he was doing all his
work and then no single teacher could be
bothered to mark his work and he got
very bitter of course and this is true
of many of the kids that I interviewed
so they're not going back into those
school because when it was important
those teachers didn't care for them so
why should they go back and give them a
second chance yes of course I mean do
you think Harriet that ofsted needs to
be overhauled somewhat or just looked at
me if there's outstanding Squad teachers
education doing I'm sorry you know why
was the Department of Education saying
hello why are some schools you know
busting a gut to teach children and
other schools doing nothing they were
doing nothing I felt quite children and
also within schools I mean one girl said
she had a great um history teacher who
was never stopped contacting her but her
English teacher she never heard of well
why was that being allowed to happen
yeah it seems quite quite extraordinary
absolutely Miriam do you think that
looking ahead if there were to be God
forbid another pandemic or whatever it
is we would think a bit more long-term
about this when it comes to kids
well I hope so and the evidence is
obviously compelling and compounding in
terms of the impact on children of
course it would depend on the nature of
the pandemic I mean I wouldn't be saying
all this if we were talking about
disease which had a 50 mortality rate
for children you know we have to get
this in proportion the reason it was the
wrong policy was because this disease
was so harmless to children and actually
although you know unfortunately lots of
people did die of or with covid
um you know the vast majority of those
that died were elderly and that you know
around the age of life expectancy in in
this country which of course sad but
it's not the same as lots and lots of
young people uh be dying from this virus
so it would depend on the pandemic but I
think we've got so much evidence now
that yes I hope it would be different
but the covert inquiry when the um terms
of reference was first published didn't
even mention children in schooling and
that is a worry you know we need to make
sure that the impact on children is
front and center of of the inquiry so
that we you know we don't forget it and
we make so we use that information in
future really great to hear from you
Maroon kids thank you so much for
joining spectator TV and Harriet
Sargeant too thank you
this week baroness Louise Casey
published a damning report into the Mets
the so-called rotten culture accusing
the force of being a cesspit of
institutional Prejudice Danny Shaw is a
journalist and formerly the BBC's home
Affairs correspondent he's gone through
the report in detail he joins me now on
the show
Danny welcome to spectator TV now
throughout your career you've been
looking at the Met police up close and
personal and what did you make of Louise
Casey's review and the findings from it
I think it's a devastating report and
what Louise Casey has done in the space
of 12 months is really impressive she
has got under the surface of the
Metropolitan Police in a way that I
don't think anyone else has no other
inquiry inspection or reporters done
that it's probably the most significant
report into the Met police that's
obviously the UK's biggest police force
um since the MacPherson inquiry report
in 1999 the difference with the
MacPherson report was that that was
looking really at the issues of race in
particular and the way that murder
inquiries were dealt with and victims
were treated this is a much more
comprehensive report that's looking at
the culture of the met the management
issues of discrimination of violence
against women and girls and she Louise
Casey has evidenced all her findings
through survey data
through interviews with people case
studies and it's it's it's a
comprehensive volume of report I've got
it here and you know if you've got if
anyone's got time
have a look through on on your website
pick up a copy if you possibly can
because it really shows you that within
a small space of time you can get to the
root of particular problems uh with a
fierce sort of Drive
um and
um you know to be honest it puts a lot
of public inquiries and other
investigations to shame because she's
managed to do in 12 months of what it
takes inquiries you know years to years
to achieve and you say that what she
found was damning can you tell us what
does she find
well her key finding is a finding an
Institutional racism misogyny and
homophobia across the Metropolitan
Police
um and discrimination she says is baked
in to the force uh there's a willful
blindness to racism she singles out two
units in the Met for particular
criticism uh mo19 which is the Firearms
command and also the Parliamentary and
diplomatic protection group as well and
says that you know there's an Insidious
culture in those organizations they're
dominated by men there's some really bad
practice and bad conduct that goes on
she says that the management of the Met
is really uncoordinated
um and you know alarmingly there seems
to be a lack of strategy a lack of sort
of forward planning and there's a real
imbalance between the center of the met
the HQ New Scotland Yard on the
embankment and the boroughs where local
policing from Frontline policing takes
place and on violence against women and
girls Louise Casey is is incredibly
critical because she says that the the
Met strategy to do that really Rings
Hollow uh because the resources the
attention The Specialist skills that are
devoted to that are just inadequate I
mean that's fascinating because we hear
so much these days about Institute
I think some viewers might be skeptical
that in a lot of these cases of
allegations surrounding those words that
they're actually fair or that they're
even relevant to the question at hand I
mean how much of this is police dealing
with incredibly stressful circumstances
for example some of the cases that we've
heard about bantering WhatsApp groups
that are completely insensitive but
ultimately probably harmless or how much
of it is actually impacting the police's
ability to do their work
well it does impact their ability to do
their work because if you're dealing
with a city like London which has you
know so many different uh ethnic groups
cultures
visitors tourists languages spoken Etc
if you don't have an attitude that you
deal with people fairly and equally no
matter what their background no matter
the color of their skin then you're not
going to be giving a good service to
people in London I mean that's that
stands to reason and so some of those
attitudes that are expressed by people
in the force they might be about their
colleagues the way that they're treated
if that's reflected in the treatment of
um of the people that they're there to
serve then that has a a terrible effect
and it's also evidenced by the data we
know for example that black people are
more likely to be stopped and searched
they're more likely to be subject to
taser they're more likely to be
restrained in police custody and so on
all those sorts of metrics and as well
as that there's other information which
shows that when people from ethnic
minorities in the police raise concerns
raise complaints then they are more
likely to be subject to allegations
themselves and are therefore put through
the misconduct process
disproportionately so that all affects
the service that londoners get
um you know if it can't treat its own
stuff well how do they expect to treat
the people of London yes I mean I saw a
shocking statistic I think it was in the
report that said over 80 percent of
officers who had allegations of domestic
abuse levied against them while still in
work rather than being investigated
um I mean when it comes to all of these
things do you think that
um
there's a vetting issue here it was a
power problem where people the power
gets you ahead of me for example those
two units that you mentioned they're
both Elite forces is that what the
problem is here that the wrong kind of
person are getting into these jobs and
they have a lot of power over others
there's no quick answer or one answer
the vetting system the Casey review
finds is broken and I think we know that
from the cases of David Carrick the
multiple rapist and domestic abuser who
was in The Met for years and numerous
opportunities to root him out with Misty
should never have been recruited we know
that there are serious problems with the
vetting uh process and some of those we
hope are being fixed and there are
efforts to do that but it's also because
the police service does attract
particular individuals there are some
people attracted to policing because it
gives them power it gives them a uniform
a warrant card and weapons and so you
know the Police Service needs to be
alive to that and I don't think they
have been sufficiently alive to that
particular problem and those units in
particular do attract a certain kind of
individual that there are many many
highly skilled professional people that
work in the Firearms unit who carry guns
and make split-second decisions that
will potentially save people's lives and
stop Terror attacks and so on and we
need to be enormously grateful for the
work that they do but at the same time
those units are dominated by a
particular type of people particular
gender particular ethnicity and that has
bred certain cultures which
um the Casey review finds are really
toxic yeah and Danny just on the topic
of
as you mentioned terrorism what about
Petty crimes because I think it's not
just londoners who feel like there's no
point in reporting a burglary or stolen
bike or anything these days and I think
there are numbers to back up that the
fact that you know even though there are
more cases of these minor crimes in
recent years fewer and few of them
actually get investigated and prosecuted
how does that relate to the topic that
we're talking about right now
well what the report does really well is
shine a light on the inadequacies of
Frontline policing where the majority of
those sort of Fairly routine crimes are
dealt with the burglaries the
shoplifting the thefts car thefts and so
on and what it shows is that resources
for Frontline policing have been eroded
over the years partly because of
austerity and partly because of choices
that the Metropolitan Police made to
prioritize other areas and to reorganize
the force in a way where the boroughs
don't really have the influence and
resources that they need and so all that
I think is playing out into the the you
know the proportion of cases that make
it through the criminal justice system
we know that the charging levels overall
across England and Wales are around five
to six percent so five out of five to
six out of a hundred crimes that are
recorded by police actually end up in
court most the vast major authority of
crimes never get anywhere near a
courtroom now those figures are not just
about the Met
um they're about you know across across
the country and it's a source of great
alarm I think for all of us and finally
Danny what is the solution here then
well there's no one simple solution uh
cultural change will take a long period
of time to affect there is some good
leadership at the met with um smart
Rowley and Damian Owens but I think
there is the need now
for some structural changes certainly we
need a plan for a structural change the
Met is not working the way it is what I
call for is for more responsibility and
accountability and resources to local
levels local boroughs the Metropolitan
Police is split into 12 basic command
units which are made up of two or three
boroughs and each of those areas
has a a complement of police officers
that's in excess of some police forces
outside London and yet those areas are
not um are not the responsibility of the
chief Constable as for example Norfolk
Police is but they're the responsibility
of a commander just above the level of
Chief superintendent now that's Madness
you know you can't put someone at that
rank in charge of such a large area and
expect a decent policing job to be done
we need a shift of resources and and
expertise to local boroughs to ensure
that we get better neighborhood policing
that will certainly be a start changing
the culture I suspect will take a lot
longer as ever Danny Shaw thank you so
much for joining spectator TV
now if you enjoy spectator TV then why
not subscribe to the magazine for just
12 pounds you can get 12 issues in print
and online at and a free 20 pound Amazon
gift voucher just go to spectator.co.uk
forward slash TV offer to subscribe
to make of cesium Payne's visit to Putin
this week has Russia been well and truly
sucked into China's orbit joining me to
discuss is Gideon rackman who's the
chief Foreign Affairs commentator for
the financial times
getting rackman thank you so much for
joining us on spectator TV now this
week's sitting ping visited Putin in
Russia and it was full of pomp as
expected what was your takeaway from
that three-day meeting well I mean I
think that
more or less as expected it was kind of
big reassertion of Russian Chinese
uh friendship and
um based around I think a mutual
antibody towards the United States and
if you read the closing document it kind
of reiterates the idea that
this is all America's fault that America
is out to cement its Global hegemony
that and that both Russia and China are
kind of have been targeted by America
and that that their joint interest is in
is in pushing back against that
um I think
there was actually rather Less on the
peace Initiative for Ukraine I thought I
never took that that seriously but I
thought that would make more of it
um but there's you know if you look at
the nine point statement it's not really
very much emphasized so I don't think
even for public relations purposes
they're making much uh of the idea that
China is going to bring peace to Ukraine
I think the big issue though that that
you wouldn't really expect them to
address publicly but that the Americans
and everybody will be watching very
closely is is China prepared to give
Russia weapons and in particular
artillery shells because the Russians
seem to be running out of those
um their bombardments of Ukrainian
infrastructure are fairly sporadic now
and that's probably because they don't
have enough missiles but China has a lot
they they use uh the same kinds of
missiles that the Russians use so if
they were to ship them over to Ukraine
that would be a big game changer in the
war
um so far I you know there was certainly
no public statement of that but
everybody watching quite closely I mean
not just in the next weeks but in the
coming months as to whether China's
prepared to
back up its rhetoric with explicit
military support for Russia and I want
to get onto that Military Support point
in just a little bit Gideon but first of
all you know your point about it not
actually being as much about mediation
as it might have seemed uh before the
visit I mean sitting seemed like he had
a wish list of things that he went to
get for China itself including for
example this power of Siberia 2 pipeline
which now channels Russian gas to China
instead of to Europe is that what he's
there for mainly to get Chinese national
interests satisfied
well I mean I think actually you know
talking to the experts it looks like
Russia is Keener on the power of Siberia
II pipeline than the Chinese because
um there's already power of Siberia one
uh you know there's a bit like Nordstrom
one and Nordstrom two and that that's
the one that takes gas to to China from
nearby Fields Russia has a dilemma now
because all the gas that it was selling
to Europe it can't sell to Europe now
the that it has been doing so over the
last year but the Europeans have
basically been devoting themselves to
the last year to finding other sources
LNG or you know Renewables whatever and
now Russia's got this this gas that they
may not be able to sell so they need a
second pipeline to get it to China but
even on the Russian timetable that won't
be until 2013.
um and then I think that clearly you
know a lot of Russians
um are concerned maybe not willing to
express it publicly unless they're in
the opposition
about Russia's growing economic
dependence on China you know that if you
read the statement it's all about this
is a relationship of equals but it looks
increasingly unequal because essentially
the rut the Russian economy is was
already much smaller than later China
it's and the massive sanctions in the
west so
you know from anything from
semiconductors 5G consumer goods they
can't get from the West
they've all got to get it all from China
and that puts she in in an immensely
powerful position
um and even if he didn't exploit it that
much now I think it must make the
Russians a little bit nervous about how
that relationship is going to unfold
because I mean if you're looking really
kind of back into history as you know
Cindy you know a lot of what is Russia
now was China in the 19th century uh and
now that of course the Russians in
Chinese say and it's technically true
they don't have a border dispute it's
all settled but um I think some Russians
do I'm worried about that in the
background absolutely and when it comes
to this dialogue between China and
Russia then Gideon I mean someone on the
Chinese side might say that that's what
makes China the perfect mediator if it
ever came to that that's why it's peace
plan is relatively sincere and uh
substantiated because you need a
mediator that can talk to both sides in
order to do that and China might point
to the Iran Saudi Arabia deal that it
recently broken where those two
countries hadn't been speaking since 2
2016 and now ah thanks to China's
negotiations what do you say to those
people
well I think it's not obviously
unreasonable point I mean I think that
if you wanted a mediator you need
somebody who can talk to Russia and um
you know people have floated India maybe
or turkey I think the difficulty is that
although China presents itself as
neutral in this
um conflict it's not really perceived
that way in the west because they have
had this uh or possibly more important
in Ukraine they have had these
protestations of unlimited friendship
which actually are interestingly a
phrase that did not occur in this latest
statement which suggested me the Chinese
might slightly regret that because it's
been thrown at them so much but you know
the spirit of Limitless friendship is
still there in the statement and I think
that the Ukrainian said well fine you
know we don't mind if China comediately
we accept that you know as we were
saying China's got a lot of Leverage
over to Russia if it wants to use it but
that the Chinese uh have at no point
condemned the Russian invasion and they
have at no Point said well Russia's got
to give back the occupied Ukrainian land
I think even if they were to be neutral
on Crimea if they were to just say look
well Russia's got to withdraw to the
lines it was before The Invasion a year
ago that might be seen as a kind of
earnest of good faith in enough in Kiev
to make them feel well okay they could
they could talk but I think if they're
not prepared to do that and if they
endorse the kind of Russian World View
which is this is a proxy war fought by
the United States this has really got
nothing to do with uh Ukraine's own
volition then I think they they kind of
lack credibility in this and I think
that as you say the Saudi Iran thing was
really interesting and I think a big
breakthrough for the Chinese and one
there can be you know maybe justifiably
proud of but it was a very different
situation that Saudis and the Iranians
were wanted to come to a deal they have
been talking behind the scenes for about
18 months and the Chinese were able to
step in at the last moment and you know
provide literally the good officers you
know they can meet and Beijing and
provide a hall and do that but I don't
think that um
that you know this conflict is similar
because the two sides are not looking to
settle and of course this is absolutely
right to say China is not completely
neutral on this I mean it is talking to
Russia but presidency hasn't spoken to
president zielinski at all since the
invasion started but we're hearing that
a phone call might happen at some point
this week did you think Ukraine has
slightly more complicated uh
relationship to handle here with China
because when and if the war ends
presumably Ukraine wants Chinese
investment to resume in the way that it
had they had before the war
yeah I I think so
um the ukrainians obviously
even in the midst of a war have to be
reasonably pragmatic and try to think
about what the world might look like
afterwards and you know there is a
a lot of Chinese investment through the
Belton Road going across the Eurasian
land mass Chinese construction firms
could potentially you know if they're
big U.N contracts play a role um in
Ukraine and why make an enemy
um prematurely if you don't need to but
that said I think it was extremely
interesting that in the very days in
which she was in Moscow kishida the
Prime Minister of Japan was in years in
Kiev and so you almost feel like the two
great rivals in East Asia are picking
different sides of this war
um and and sort of you know for all the
talk of proxy war maybe it's now also
becoming a proxy rivalry between China
and Japan goody
um and Gideon finally you know you
mentioned military aid at the beginning
um on the latest Chinese whisp was my
podcast I spoke to senior Colonel jobor
who used to be in the people's
Liberation Army so pretty much as
establishment as you can get and I know
that he's written for the financial
times previously as well and he was
pretty clear that the Chinese would not
be giving Military Arms not because he
was trying to spin me necessarily but
because he was saying wouldn't be in
China's interest to get involved in that
way because then China then becomes even
more of a baddie but you don't seem to
think that that completely rules out
this idea of military involvement no I
mean I I don't I mean I I hope he's
right
um because obviously it would be a
really dangerous escalation if they did
it and very bad news for Ukraine
incidentally
um but I suspect that you know Beijing
is a bit like Washington or Moscow there
are debates
um you know they may be a bit more
hidden in a in a society like China's
where they don't obviously encourage
people to descend from whatever the line
is
um but there will be discussions going
on and I would imagine uh that there's a
counter school that will say look
um what Putin and she said is correct uh
America's targeting both of us and we
cannot afford to let Russia lose so they
may not do it now but if they actually
saw a real danger of uh Russian
capitulation there might be a temptation
to do it just as you know if Kiev was
suddenly under threat again a lot of
people in the west would say you know
get as much Aid as you can to Ukraine
fast I think that you know stalemate
they can live with a Russian defeat
might or the prospect of a Russian
defeat might open up the question of of
direct military aid or you know it may
even be under discussion now the
Americans say that actually they think
the Chinese are sending stuff to uh to
uh to Russia not yet the very visible
artillery shells that would be crucial
but drone technology there's some you
know a large uh Consignment of what
we're called hunting rifles went uh from
China to Russia uh semiconductors would
do all use that kind of thing and they
can always root stuff
um you know through third parties so I
think the US is pretty concerned about
this and presumably uh they they are
listening to and watching what's going
on in Beijing quite closely great to
have you on the show thank you so much
Gideon
and finally it's been just over a year
since the James Webb Telescope was
launched by NASA and scientists have now
spotted more than 5 000 planets beyond
our solar system but the aspect emit for
those we haven't discovered is well very
much more what do we know about these
mystery planets and what does this mean
for Humanity's search for alien life I'm
joined by the professor of physics and
astronomy at Exeter University Sasha
Hinckley
Sasha welcome to spectator TV perhaps a
good place to start um today would be
just to talk about your role on the
James Webb Telescope leading these 120
scientists what is it
well I've been really fortunate actually
to be
um one of the first leading a team that
is is getting some of the first
observations from the James Webb Space
Telescope or jwst as we as we call it uh
the The Institute that runs the James
Webb Space Telescope wanted to see whole
communities come together and sort of
test drive this Observatory for the
first time because this is by far the
most technologically advanced
Observatory that NASA has ever launched
into space and they really wanted to
make sure that we're we understand early
on how to use this and specifically for
these really challenging observations
like detecting extrasolar planets and
then you these are shortened to
exoplanets and so tell us what is an
exoplanet
so an exoplanet is short for extra Solar
Planet and this is a planet that is
orbiting a star other than our own sun
and we've about 30 years ago we only
sort of hypothesized that these things
might exist but now we know of thousands
it's just been an explosion actually in
our knowledge about extrasolar planets
exoplanets and now we're starting to
characterize them in detail and learn
things about their compositions whether
they have atmospheres oceans things like
that so have we found water outside of
the solar system then
yes plenty water is actually an
incredibly abundance
constituent of atmospheres of extrasolar
planets but we don't actually know yet
whether these exoplanets have oceans on
them yet but we certainly have uh
detected water on these in these
atmospheres of these of these planets
Sasha this might be a stupid question
but how do we detect water or any other
chemical components in these planets
which are presumably very very far away
that's not at all a stupid question
actually it's a very sort of challenging
and interesting question astronomers are
uh we're a bit of an odd Bunch really
because we're not as lucky as biologists
or chemists where if we want to make a
measurement we can go into our
laboratory use a ruler or a scale or a
magnifying glass or something
astronomers have to get all of our
information just from the very very
faint light that comes from whatever
object it is we're observing so
typically what we do is we break this
light into its constituent wavelengths
and search for the chemical signatures
of whatever it is we're looking for
within this light
so could you explain that a little bit
more
absolutely so on a rainy day just as a
rain shower might break the sunlight
into its constituent colors we do the
same thing we actually take light that's
a combination of many many different
colors from a star or an exoplanet and
we break it up into its constituent
wavelengths or light colors of light if
you will and the degree to which it has
more or less water carbon dioxide
methane something like that the various
levels of these colors of light will go
up and down and so this provides sort of
a signature for detecting these various
compounds like water like you mentioned
that's amazing and obviously we're
trying to learn all about this as you
say in the piece is to understand how
planets are formed and how planets die
but you also say in the piece that this
could help us find alien life forms as
well tell us about that
yeah so
what if I told you that I think it's
quite likely that we're probably going
to collect evidence for Bio signatures
which could mean life on another planet
within my lifetime I really think that
that's going to happen we have all the
tools and we have plans to to do that
and it might even happen with the James
Webb Space Telescope coming up
and what kind of life forms are we
talking about here we're talking about
Star Wars star civilizations or are we
talking about really kind of the
fundamental parts of the very primitive
sorts of life
that's a great question uh
it's it's probably not going to be the
case that we detect full civilizations
or even make contacts with them uh but
more likely what we're probably going to
find within my lifetime are what we call
these bio signatures and these are not
like um you know a picture of somebody
waving at you from a from an
extracellular planet or something like
that we actually look for uh kind of
imbalances in the chemistries of these
atmospheres of these planets that might
indicate something is altering the
chemistry in a way that would indicate
potentially the presence of life so this
is what astronomers talk about when we
talk about uh detecting life on other
planets we talk about bio signatures and
usually this is just
um a chemical signature if you will
it does sound a bit Fantastical when we
start talking about alien life but for
you I mean the evidence I'm inclined to
believe you certainly because as you
write there's so many of it these
exoplanets out there can you give us an
idea of you know you said about a
thousands that we've already spotted but
there's more than we've just spotted
isn't there
absolutely so
one of the provocative questions that
was raised by Carl Sagan uh who was this
sort of pioneering American astronomer
that had this um really Landmark
television series he raised this
question are there more planets in the
universe or are there more grains of
sand on all the beaches of the world
and this is actually a calculation that
I do with my students it's a fairly
simple one and the answer is that there
are many many more planets than there
are grains of sand on all the beaches of
the world probably by a factor of 10 or
100.
so this is really an amazing idea next
time you're at the beach grab a handful
of sand and let it let the sand sort of
slip through your fingers and imagine
that all those are planets
we now know that most stars have planets
and we know that the planets that they
host are
something like our own Earth they're
either sort of more massive versions of
our own Earth or they may even be sort
of miniature versions of something more
like our own Neptune we're not really
sure what the what the actual
characteristics of them are but I think
just the sheer numbers uh and by the way
we don't have a number for this as I go
into the article uh the number of
exoplanets that we can imagine in the
universe would be a one followed by 22
zeros so we don't have a number for that
but that gives you sort of a
mind-blowing
sense of the of the scale that we're
talking about here so my feeling is that
with such an incredible number of
exoplanets
um that there must be some possibility
for life in the universe and I think
that we are going to see some evidence
of of the detection of Bio signatures
um in my lifetime this is so fascinating
because as you write about um in your
piece you also mentioned a Fermi Paradox
this idea that if the universe is so
teeming with life why haven't we spotted
anything yet and obviously being a
paradox no one has come up with a
convincing answer if that satisfies
everyone but I just wonder what you
think about the theory that actually
um the answer to that is something of a
Dark Forest idea where if you're in a
dark forest and other animals are there
but no one is making themselves known
that's because the ones that do make
themselves known are the ones that are
preyed upon it does seem like humanity
is advertising our existence to the rest
of the universe could that be an answer
to the Fermi Paradox do you think
perhaps
um I don't know what the answer is uh I
like your I like your hypothesis though
I think one of the issues that we Face
are just the truly staggering distances
within the universe and communication
and certainly travel between life forms
in the universe is is just incredibly
prohibitive but nonetheless there's a
new field that has really emerged in the
last 10 or 20 years and we call it
astrobiology sounds like a bit of a
strange field but
um organizations like NASA are taking
this very very seriously and this is now
a well-respected academic discipline we
have journals we have conferences we
have people that are astrobiologists and
they don't actually do things like sit
around and speculate about
um what kind of skyscrapers and alien
civilization might
build or something like that they're
actually more studying things right here
on Earth uh typically sort of microbial
life forms that we call extremophiles
and these are
um you know primitive multicellular life
forms that might exist in very very
harsh environments on Earth maybe a very
hot undersea ocean event or maybe a
highly acidic volcanic Lake for example
and so what astrobiologists are
interested in learning about is the
degree to which life is resilient
assist in these incredibly harsh
environments that we might find on an
extrasolar plant that is either very hot
very cold very strongly irradiated by
its host star so maybe by learning about
these incredible uh extremo files here
on Earth we might be able to learn
something about the possibility for
biology existing on other planets that's
fascinating and finally such as you lead
it to you at the beginning in 30 years
we've made so much progress do you think
that the speed of progress when it comes
to this field is exponential so we're
going to be seeing many more folds of
progress in the years to come in a
shorter period of time
absolutely the next two decades are
really going to be an exciting time I
think the best example of this is that
in the United States the National
Academy of Sciences convenes a blue
ribbon panel of experts that sit
together in a room for a couple of years
and they make recommendations for where
they think astronomy should go in the
next decade and this has major
repercussions for where funding goes in
astronomy and their number one
recommendation in their 2020 survey was
that NASA should get behind building a
dedicated space mission to study a
handful of Earth-like planets orbiting
other stars to really search for these
bio signatures and the fact that this
committee made this as their number one
recommendation means that there are
already people working on this mission
that will probably fly in the 2040s so
that's why I think it's quite sensible
to think that in my lifetime we'll see
evidence of files signatures uh detected
on another planet
Sasha Hinckley thank you so much for
joining spectator TV
it's been a pleasure talking with you
thank you
that's it for this week if you enjoy
spectator TV subscribe to our YouTube
channel click the Subscribe button at
the bottom of this video and tap the
Bell icon so you never miss any of our
videos
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]